[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
alors l'idée de ce coeur qui est née il
ya maintenant quasiment 30 ans était de
créer un dispositif qui pouvait se
substituer à la transplantation
cardiaque donc à un dispositif qui
fonctionne d'une manière physiologiques
tels un coeur humain donc pulsatile auto
régulée et mot compatibles
[Musique]
ici on a un pièce où on fait les tests
sur bancs d'essai donc on a une douzaine
de machines en ligne est là derrière moi
vous voyez on enfin faire quelques
changements on est en train de tester
des changements sur une prothèse
[Musique]
c'est permettre à des gens jeunes qui
ont une espérance de vie importante de
pouvoir attendre un coeur donc ça c'est
le pour la transplantation ou autrement
il ya la thérapie définitive qui est
permet pas un patient qui ne pourra pas
être éligible dans la liste d'attenté
est bien d'avoir un dispositif qui lui
permettra de vivre le plus longtemps
possible
mais aujourd'hui on est on tombe dans la
première indication en effet quitte pour
la transplantation
mais notre but toujours c'est travailler
pour avoir une extension d'indication
dans le futur pour pouvoir adresser les
deux types de population
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]